[Music]
welcome back Jim Norton is reentering
the studio as we speak
and dance odors here oh hi say you're
welcome scares the piss can they know
the good time to clean the bathrooms 914
in the morning so Stu where you're
cleaning it right now yes yes I've never
came here at this time it's [ __ ]
hellacious yeah downstairs just even to
get an idea it's the nightmare even
again I was going to the subways like
this is this what regular every piece I
think I know what to do this but the
bottom line the fact that they closed
the downstairs bathroom at 9:00 a.m.
it's like hey dummy do it at 7:00 or
6:30 there's less people I used to be
here like at midnight not one
inconvenience in this entire building
occurs at midnight nothing no that's me
yeah
nothing I've been here everything's easy
and they've cleaned the bathrooms yeah
you should do that late yeah they do it
yeah they don't 9:15 in the more it's
ridiculous at the run of the steps and
you got to get back on the air - why
would she do that
I don't know get it probably I mean
she's probably assigned to do it by
somebody but I mean well yet yeah get it
here an hour early or she's a very
calculating janitor right and she's
sitting there going like oh really this
is the highest trafficked time period
well let's see you hold it now night
fancy [ __ ] just gonna have to
do some cleaning maybe walk up a flight
of stairs but no-one's but the bottom
line is the bathroom could be that dirty
yet if you do it at night how dirty is
it by 9:00 in the morning oh [ __ ] it all
bad it is a should be done at night but
it's not no it is done at night like it
couldn't be done well no I mean I was I
was here it's done it like like seven
o'clock at night every night no I'm
thinking like after the night shift
leaves 12:00 1:00 get someone here to do
them so they come in the morning I tell
you why because the overnight people
from shade 45 and the sports channels
animals are [ __ ] animal especially
you know people always blame shade 45
but it's the big fat cells that are here
overnight with sports it's better than
the Jets
I've got paper laid down in my studio so
I can make a pee-pee yeah yeah there's
[ __ ] like hamsters right now
yeah trying to convince Domino's to stay
open till 3 o'clock in the morning to
deliver their pizza there guys open up
here that I guess there are 24 hour
broadcast for hours yeah especially the
sports guys imagine doing a 3 a.m.
broadcast you had to press
and just and that's why they make a mess
of the bathroom are they the ones who
was [ __ ] all over the place I think
so I don't have any any any hard
evidence but I would I would say yes I
think if you set up a motion-detecting
carry a you probably see that you
probably find that to be true
I think so they're an angry bunch yeah
they are what they all wanted to be
athletes and then they all wanted to be
sports radio personalities and then they
already sports radio producers and
they're and then they got the overnight
shift there's no breaking news in sports
at 3:00 a.m. there are now during
[ __ ] cricket in India right right
that's a depressing shift it's bad
[ __ ] I think about that oh you been here
that late and there's always people here
yeah I mean it's significantly less
people but yeah there's always somebody
here overnights and radio were the worst
you see the worst people you definitely
see the worst people I used to work
overnights in Tucson at a radio station
kfm a and there's a classic rock station
and the guy was a strip club DJ and he
had all these radio ideas this is what I
used to just smoke weed in the parking
lot but one time he's like I got the
melting pot coming down here we're gonna
do a giveaway it was 2:30 in the morning
in Tucson and he's like I got two
winners coming down here they went out
they came to the studio clearly meth
heads just clearly meth heads that were
listening to the radio eating fondue it
was one of the many states I never said
this guy's a scratch he's like I'm
excited to get this $50 thing yeah Mike
the guy's deejay was like this is
awesome this is a good start dude
giveaways all the time now I'm like
that's all you're gonna get is methane
yeah for the two methods that are
listening yeah someone in a domestic
dispute or a method yeah Jim listen to
art bell overnight that was an overnight
show coast to coast oh yeah oh my god
that's like classic radio isn't it he
was five hours and night no one could
milk a subject oh my god bail and he
knew how to keep you on coming up we're
gonna talk about this and that and then
they could kind of get to this to that
but he just he's one of the best ever
he's great man it's all like are aliens
real conspiracy theory like all the
weird [ __ ] that you think about late at
night that's perfect he'd be sitting
there like for all the coast-to-coast
drivers and the people that consol look
at him and the meth heads like and he
would just sit there and every night
he'd have
maybe it's like a five-hour radio show
already show one guest he do one guest
any smokes smokes like cloves oh yeah he
looks like a guy that smokes cloves that
was a fun guest - wasn't like an
in-studio guest he just talked to one
person who wrote a book on the phone all
night that's right heard of Michio Kaku
because dr. Kaku was actually a really
good guest on our pillow show yeah he
would call it and he would stay on them
all night or for three hours was amazing
you Dave you must have an ISDN in your
house if you're gonna be on that long
you can't be sitting there on the
[ __ ] phone three hours
absolutely connection between your
shoulder and your ear just holding on to
the eye bag
IDs a terrible person to get caught in a
conversation with at during like the day
real like god this guy's goes right and
don't speak slowly yeah well yeah you
find that closer you hard I got it yes
II know he was really good like he would
keep you on the hook but you know Joe
you were also captive a little bit yeah
yeah yeah you would that buddy would
keep you there like I would I would not
want to stop listening which is he dead
is he still alive II won he's 71 he
should interview these late-night sports
guys worried duty or audio his voice
really great you don't know he sounds
like I've drawn off sans impression not
an impression no it's more I'm more
catching kept capturing the essence oh I
like that that's me my impressions are
more about the essence yeah yeah
I get it I got you I put out the video
of you and I are you doing a macho man
impression of me doing the whole Cogan
impression your essence is there my eye
the essence of Hulk Hogan but a lot of
people pointed out not not so much with
the voice no but I felt the essence I
was in the room I appreciate that
yeah I felt that was really awful
allegation he's got a crate then others
began repeating it you see but I can't
no okay uh to be very you don't see the
slow I want to be always got it wobble
as moist not naming me Luna it is art
but of course yes catcher who had
attacked my son okay well I immediately
contacted premiere radio excessive
[ __ ] yeah that's radio I could see
how you could listen to him for five
hours yeah you could listen to that that
he's a voice and and that's our bell
2013 he's older is I I listen to
him mostly riding around again we were
kicked off the air in 2003 and for I was
really off the deep end and 2000 and I
would spend hours every night riding
around listening to this guy you smoke
and generate earlier than that
so I didn't smoke at the time I would
just seems like it'd be great radio show
to smoke cigarettes to [ __ ] alone in
your house yeah
I'd listen to Eric Bogosian that was
mine who's that that is mine I wish your
career done the same way you're dead
[ __ ] oh man so what's been going on
Dan hasn't this it it's nice to be in
here it's good to see you guys yes been
a little while even you got some house
heroes yours is tests show oh my god
well we passed with flying colors you
did huh
this the early it's fun to be back yeah
you've been doing billions is that
what's been going on yeah almost done we
have one more episode of how many do you
shoot a season um like how many episode
12 okay so we're on Episode twelve right
now we just started episode 12 how many
ever searchin 12 every episode of
billions yeah pop up in every episode
and count some bigger than others but
it's cool it's a good season really good
season
what is it season two yeah it's one of
those things where season two like
season when they established all the
characters and now there's some really
cool [ __ ] happening right so February
17th comes up show time do you shoot
with Damian Lewis yeah he's my boss he
screams at me a lot he's great man he is
the [ __ ] best
and I've became comfortable with him
yelling at me in a weird way cuz I get
the script and it's always like I'll
[ __ ] up or something will happen in an
episode and he'll just yell at me and
you just become comfortable someone it's
like yeah like a stepdad comfortability
look like yes I would say yeah you you
you reaching out needing a father I
never would have guessed that no not you
I don't think that would come up Oh
with Damian Lewis is screaming at you
and reprimanded you
yeah sit there and be like this is what
I needed growing up like more of it
balancing me as a man yeah
off camera he's [ __ ] great oh he is
okay yeah the entire him and David
Costabile and everyone I work with is
like they're really cool and it's at an
office so it feels like I'm always
mostly at this office so it feels kind
of like an office job like where I go I
have a desk I have a permanent desk at
this place really yeah I keep [ __ ]
it's kind of weird have you blown any
takes yeah
season one
they cut my scene from the season finale
because it really didn't have to do a
lot with the thing but I just kept
[ __ ] the line up and Damian Lewis
shot me a look of like come on like I'm
like just like a come on and I was like
all right no no I'll say they kept
fumbling the the numbers didn't make you
did that make you more scarce I always
the line do you remember uh it was
something about a bonus and I I talked
about my stat sheet I forget the exact
like line but it was like my stats are
better and I kept saying the wrong stats
and he'd be like what if I cut and I
back out start out Jesus and like after
3 it was like ah [ __ ] man I'm sorry and
that I like I had to do like a little it
was some happen come back and then kind
of got it yeah I finally got it then
they cut the scene but he was getting
annoyed he got annoyed like the second
or third mistake like come on man ah
because it's the end of the season and
that guy works his ass off him and Paul
Giamatti yeah like you know Paul
Giamatti great is he great guy yeah I
don't really work with him a lot but
like table reads and all the stuff where
I see him he's [ __ ] super nice yeah
the entire cast is great give your lines
from private parts in front of him I
want you I had 12 years a slave I try to
do my best Thomas Haden Church from
sideways B I don't really you know I
don't really work with him a lot but
everyone's real cool yeah and the only
time I [ __ ] up I felt real bad he did
really especially since the line was
like something that the series was
centered around my bonus says that we
made yeah
billions oh look at the camera that's
why it's called that finally you get the
name in the show but I'm sure he blown
takes uh he doesn't like super
professional ways we were like okay you
just can't you know he's the guy plus
it's like yeah I mean he's Damian Lewis
it's not like you're gonna be like oh no
I don't feel like man gives like these
huge speeches were you like what said
the wrong word we're all waiting for you
Damian it like [ __ ] off but if someone
[ __ ] up it doesn't make you feel bad if
you [ __ ] up yeah yeah I've seen yeah
people have [ __ ] up before really okay
I know it's the worst if you're only out
for a day like you're doing one episode
you keep blowing so know who is the
community on Rao's told the story he had
a part in men in black yeah we're here
to back up in Tommy Lee Jones and Will
Smith or walkie and he had these lines
to do but he's I kept [ __ ] up so they
finally just took me out and made me
stand up there and gave another guy is
lying oh that's the nightmare that I'd
be so worried about every time I hear
one of these stories I think about how I
would be like if Damian Lewis looked at
me I'd be like they're gonna figure out
that I should not be here
that's all I fire me of course this is
it all I can think it was like I'm not
coming back on season two right there's
no welcome back up season but then to
hear that actually happened to somebody
like okay we're just gonna sing for
Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith [ __ ] me
I've seen something worse for this I
watched an extra get fired in like in
like a brutal way yeah they're just like
get you're gone
get him a D it was like a really
complicated shoot where there was a lot
of people in this there's like sometimes
extras it's almost like the show with
Gervase where they try to be like loud
and boisterous to like get themselves
noticed yeah and this assistant director
just he's the best and he just [ __ ]
wasn't having it that day was like a
16-hour day and he's like get him the
[ __ ] out of here and that guy like had
to walk like the entire almost entire
cast is there and you're like what is
just like a he's just the guy who's like
a fox sorry man
do you think the guy noticed that
everybody else heard that he got fired
dude it was you standing on like a
balcony yelling down that that guy was
fired it was like a nice diamond killing
he just kept his cell phone went off one
time which is just super unprofessional
but that happens sometimes and then he
kept talking loud and they're like we
need silence on this we need to get this
one thing everyone be quiet just
pantomime any was like kind of being
loud I'm good [ __ ] him yeah but it was
one of those things where it's like [ __ ]
him but then it happened and it came
down and you're like heal yourself on on
on a set and yura net I look even if I'm
innocent I was how much [ __ ] phone on
it's gotta be off you're an extra you
know how to turn your phone off yeah I
was pretty day me and Louis on what he
doing he has one of those things Rose
like I I wouldn't I just assume they're
just gonna start handing out fires like
you're fired you're fired and ran
remember last season we all remember
that and they all know who was here oh
yeah dude that will that got ya the guy
was like should he cheat anyone else
snitch them they're like it's this guy
it was just like your [ __ ] with him yeah
I really did it was like what does
things really cool
ah geez her to leave leave the set in
front of everybody yeah he's embarrassed
dude look at his face he's like well I
just I'll just go collect my thing I've
never seen a human that was so
physically obvious his tail was between
us if he had a tail it would have been
between his legs there's no there's no
room for him to be like no wasn't me
talk dude nah man everybody kept talking
loud there's there's just been I think
he just wanted probably some attention
on himself
one times extras are crazy yeah they're
cramming you got to stand there it's an
awful job awful job and you're just
saying one thing you don't do is talk
loud during the scene ha dude one guy
called me and I didn't want to get him
in trouble I didn't get him in trouble
and I could have but this one guy called
me in another actor a douche and I heard
him and I confronted him about it and it
was the most awkward I've ever seen a
person why did he call you douche I mean
it's obvious but why would you what do
you notice there's just like a cold day
filming and we got to go inside I guess
they kept putting us and you know but
like are you guys can go back to your
trailers where they're warm and then we
came back out and he's like oh look we
could stand by the douchebags I was like
he's trying to say to his buddy I go
what did you say and he was just that
thing or he's like what we get to
standbys walk he did the best little kid
lie thing or he goes I was I was quoting
a song I get to stand by the tune to
Katy Perry song romantic song yeah and
then you know like I pulled him aside
after like you owe me a watch what
you're saying cuz I might I might be a
[ __ ] I could [ __ ] go to you know
somebody and try to get you fired but I
understand you're pissed because you're
out in the cold
I was actually humane about it but dude
he's an event yeah the catching him was
just the best cuz he just [ __ ] you
humane about it but you did take him
aside go you know I could get you fired
well please Caligula don't right I don't
blame you to power to putting a little
[ __ ] the screws on the counter a
little bit this is a Hydra who's
probably been like working for years and
liked it all cuz she's my dumb head be
like dunno if we're gonna do this guy
and you pull him over and be like let me
give you some advice jr. yeah when
you're in the scene be in the city they
get jealous when a [ __ ] when the cat
gets to go into the trailers get warm
yes that's what makes the job dude so
much worse percent there is absolutely a
moment where we were all like like all
right because you know they call them
principals like principals can go inside
and we're like we have these jackets
like babies hurricane jackets know like
in suits just like wow that sucks yeah
it's a rough job man breathless I mean
you know anybody that's been an extra
you know you sign up for that [ __ ] but
that's what makes being an extra so much
worse it's not even just that it's a
long day and blah blah blah it's that
the reason you're an extra is because
you want to be a principal you want it
like you want you want so badly just to
be on the TV but it's like you just want
to be on the TV but it's like an
Internet or radio station when you see
like interns or radio stations like what
are you doing yeah it's kind of that
same thing about you want it bad it's so
bad that you can't wait for an ample
opportunity right what is bad enough
that you're [ __ ] the whole mess out
they have a thing they do voice looping
for uh like for these background noises
and background people chatter that uh
this is a hole in an enclosed industry I
know girl does it and she's like the
same people do it all the time you got
to do accents sometimes like oh so like
filling in noise little background noise
where could they shoot silently and
they're not recording the extra so if
they have to boost it up a little bit
they do all these and they use the same
people for loopy the pilots very
lucrative yeah it's hard to get in a
secret society of background it really
is the lucrative the [ __ ] looping
people and Illuminati as you say do you
think they have masks [ __ ] parties yes
they all [ __ ] rocky Dennis
haha there goes Stokes put on the mask
again what yeah mom said my face feel
stupid you need a woman to rate a man
that runs your lipstick not your mascara
that's in that Sam Elliott I guess so
he's the boyfriend is it mask yeah time
to kid washing morning criminals yeah
yeah I want to get into that we need to
find out how to break into that
background noise yeah I didn't even know
it was the thing I just seen they record
everybody just practice yeah I think we
did it done I think the three of us
could probably just do an entire
background let's make our own society
can we still do masks [ __ ] parties yeah
the guy's wide shut except with three
dude three dudes goat bass yeah that all
know who each other are how sexy was
that girl by the way in that movie
well Cole Kidman no no no the one of the
party yeah the other turns out she's got
HIV I fell asleep during that movie too
really that is like maybe a narcoleptic
yeah no I was like sure [ __ ] that that's
a movie we could fall asleep that's a
long movie
who's good enough and what I like it but
it is I I am aware of the slowness of it
slow it grew on me after but I loved it
too a clue I really liked I didn't like
the first time I was a little weird
because you know like it's supposed to
look like New York is not shot like New
York Kubrick hated New York's like he
shot in England which was a mistake it's
uh
I kept thinking at the sex parties how
cold or how shriveled my dick would be
if I was naked in one of those robes and
my feet were on the cold tile maybe they
were heated oh that's true but you don't
know if it was cold I was white guys
can't get a corner yank real quick
before I disrobe it plus it was like
what 96 they probably weren't heated in
96 not yet the first time I can remember
hearing about heated tiles was in
Breaking Bad yes I don't so I don't know
if that was we were deep into the 2000s
I think I needed tiling came out I think
we might have been in the first Obama
administration oh I have heated floors
oh excuse me
yeah do you need them but in the
bathroom only oh wow
um [ __ ] freezing my part I have the
opposite in my kitchen a pipe broke four
years ago and it warped aboard so now
it's like a little
like a hockey bag it's like a teepee all
the way down the center of my kitchen
I've had several friends roll their
ankles going to get a glass of water
money if it's it more just get them the
glass of water my landlord and I have
this weird thing where he doesn't fix
[ __ ] but like he doesn't also raise rent
so did you ever ask him to fix this yeah
what'd he say say oh yeah he's names
Anthony's like I eat Dan I'll be buying
me never comes back but then he raised
the rent if he fixed it that's one word
and you're like I don't need that I
don't show marry someone because I'm
trying to bank Ted might do I'm trying
to bank that billions money that would
drive me nuts
oh yeah but I mean we're kind of used to
it Becky on and I get used to it I don't
like a [ __ ] any type of finicky trip
over it's well I cover my kitchen booby
trap Nydia right the girl comes in oh my
gosh go get a glass of water I've seen
the place that you used to live in
though I mean it was terrible the
apartment you lived in with Florentine
dad was disgusting guys we can't live
Jude New Jersey it's black mold all over
the walls is horrible all over the walls
yes buddy there might be black mold
under this hump in the kitchen though
Molly is that's probably the hump is
it's a black mold forcing its way out
here and you say the other day that it
was infested with silverfish yes so then
what are you giving Dan a hard time
because I was a mess then I'm saying you
could fix it dance okay first I was this
is 19 this was on 99 I lived there Dan's
getting out of his mess phase right now
though he's got a like he's still kind
of owning the fact that he's a bit of a
mess even though he's not really a mess
anymore kind of right I'm almost longing
for the days of being us right and
that's why you're not ready to move out
it you could move to a nicer place now
but you don't want to I like my
apartment in Queens another fort anyway
there's a [ __ ] hump in you're ready
to move yeah how much it month is rent
well I paid 1,300 okay write it move any
10 years in Queens you don't need to be
there so longest I've ever lived in a
placement you like it I like it how long
is my even might live there six years
all right you know like well then yeah
but he doesn't want you know it that it
here you don't want to be in that place
where it's like I've I've moved up a
little bit I've been like [ __ ] you Queen
exactly ever come back here right you're
ready to move to Manhattan yeah I think
so hey I think you could be a maid in
Manhattan but you don't want to lose
that that that essence of Dan Soder the
real the Queen's boy I am Queens
Boulevard
I am mountain trash I just happen to
leave it was the audio track that was
removed they probably put some [ __ ]
like this year old is this man under it
like a MTV Cribs bed yeah I think they
made it sound like MTV Cribs since way
is this your old place that they're
moving [ __ ] yeah that was a behind a
picture oh boy was em seated on walls
yep
how did that [ __ ] just get up on that
looks like you tried scratching through
the walls like Shawshank Redemption I
then who's the big fat guys I love your
hahaha I love your watch salesman cell
phone I think you're [ __ ] old
cellphone I think that we um that
picture is just there to hide mold oh
yeah my CDs yeah CD collections really
there's my laundry bag in the back
you're playing [ __ ] chess like you're
like you're a member of high society no
this is where you live I play alone in
my Etsy the ceiling was buckling cause
of water damage that's great
was that was that damaged I was doing
stand-up a decade at this point do you
prefer the place you live in now I do
okay he's got heated floors it does go
that alone it could be in that apartment
with you two floors Vic that's not that
bad what's in the Tupperware
well that was Jim Jim's girlfriend Jade
was a dancer and she had all those uh
gener you like all over different
costumes yeah in in separate I just
wanna close she's like tonight's gonna
be calm come next a rope cowgirl yeah
they come messy that was [ __ ] uh when
I lived with all right we had another
roommate Mike and I had so I lived in
the windowless room which is a closet
right up until two years ago and when
the three when you were dead honest as
cheap right it was like I was only
paying like 665 bucks
so [ __ ] yeah yeah right six six bikes
let me borrow a dollar right give me a
buck I'll give you a turtle damnation so
cool so cool I actually did really enjoy
that I know I was supposed to but I
really did but when the three of us
lived there it was [ __ ] so messy
yes all of Becky own [ __ ] was in the
living room it looked like we robbed
houses and this is where we put
everything
is random [ __ ] and then our couch was
like pushed basically to the door
because it's a sectional couch so the
living room is just like right in your
face it's a pretty now you like walking
like oh it's like a good living room
doesn't it drive you nuts to share space
by the P I couldn't do it again yeah I
don't I think I was just so conditioned
because when I moved into that apartment
I didn't have [ __ ] oh I had two
suitcases in an air mattress so the more
[ __ ] that I got I was like look at all
this stuff
I became like a pack rattling right look
at all my stuff but you'd have to bring
a girl and you met a girl you'd have to
get her to convince her to come back to
Queens and a windowless room and then go
into the messy living room laughter all
I did take her to your walk-in closet
the last girl I dated I showed her my
old room I go this is the room I lived
in for eight years and she goes how did
you [ __ ] anybody you should have hung
curtains to make it look like you have a
window that's closed yeah oh don't worry
I don't want to open the window it is a
draft yeah see I just put like a blinder
shade out and I cannot leave that down I
have her thinking about which side of
the building we're all pretty sure
there's just another building on this
house there a window yeah dottie more
yeah yeah it was a and there was a
heater so just kick heat in the room so
if you didn't have the door open it got
[ __ ] terrible I remember one time an
ex-girlfriend I woke up both like like
sweating in the middle Helen you live in
that little room eight or eight years
that's too long way too long yeah I
started becoming a mean person so no
wonder like now yeah you're out of the
room he's right you just think as long
that your room was like that movie room
yeah yeah like that's where you live I
wrote I raised a son right
that was like raped into bread Becky
Owen would come in and rape you every
night yeah powerful former wrestler very
powerful base right can't get around him
yeah and then I finally when I moved
into the room with the window I was like
finally made it you like it yes can we
crack that window that's raining now let
me get a little fresh air I slept with
the window open last night I love the
open it's great it's too cold 1d see
this is the thing about a lot of older
place that sucks you can't control the
heat no that makes me not my own you
can't control the heat really
oh [ __ ] it on my belt off dude it's the
worst and there's an Anthony won't turn
on the heat my landlord until like the
very last second so we have space
heaters in and then finally he'll just
[ __ ] one day you're walking it'll be
like 82
guy yeah but he doesn't raise the rent
so I appreciate that well then maybe
there's a reason to raise the rent is
terrible quality of life I don't know
we've been month-to-month for ten years
anomaly why I don't know don't ask
what's better yeah am I sure this is all
real shady thing that's okay
in my building they it's all old people
that have been there for a long time so
the heat comes on way too early and
stays on get some sway too long you get
some September heat
oh yeah it's awful we don't crack ours
neighbor on it the old people we get cuz
they'll call up the landlord and be like
it's too cold I don't understand so in
the winter we have to open the windows
you can't turn your heat off I thought
why I don't understand why buildings
still do that well I mean it's an old
building it's not like it's there making
the choice to do it now it's drives me
nuts they can't fix left what they call
it but then I would have to same thing I
have to pay a whole bunch more rent if
they came in that's they do they come in
and make repairs to every apartment then
they're gonna really up charge you
because they've done that before they
came in they're like good news we're
getting new windows everybody and
everybody was like cool and the new
windows are great they're like and
here's the new cost of living here yeah
how much more was it there's a couple
hundred bucks a month
that's seed that's for Windows yeah but
this is a great advertisement for
anybody that's thinking about moving to
the tri-state area like you will just
get [ __ ] if you don't have a lot of
moaning yeah yeah thank God I said yes
and where was this place this was in
Cliffside Park New Jersey and I'm
watching done watching as we talk and
she's bringing back so many memories
like how long did you and Jim lived
there for I lived there with him and his
first girlfriend and then was just being
Jim and then his second girlfriend three
years when we have a patio mmm leads out
like a little tiny thing but the door
that leads out to it is the worst door
you've ever seen and literally just
paint chip falls off at our dog our dog
eats the paint chips the fall off the
ground all the time but we're trying to
because we're gonna put the kid when
Jess has the kid we're gonna put it
right next to where the door is
wait hold on you're having a kid yeah
then I tell you I didn't tell that my
pregnant you guys are pregnant
attentional chipper Jim Jim Jim Jim's
the mother Jim is the mom Alex will you
look right you're not showing is your
mom gonna dote on the baby yeah
yeah they'd still be all over the kids
she's gonna show up at the apartment on
announced are you know that oh yeah
so yeah for the baby we brought yeah I'm
very gonna have to find more things to
do in the city cuz I'm sure my mom she's
gonna be there all the time
she allowing you to name the baby after
a wrestler we don't I don't know what
we're gonna name the baby yet we're
still working on that means I'm sure
I'll figure out some obscure wrestler
that she doesn't know about or something
she's like alright loves her Brody yeah
yeah bruiser Brody and Regan hey bruiser
Brody Robert it's a good strong name but
we're trying to we're using that to tell
the landlord that we need the door
replaced because the paint chips are
falling off as otherwise he'll charge us
for replacing the door even though I'm
sure it's unhealthy yeah you got to put
a baby in front but we put the baby and
then we're like hey this is a hazard
maybe you have to change it maybe I
should fake a baby thing to be like hey
can you fix our kitchen my toddler's
walking around yeah what kind of couple
yeah bring up just [ __ ] you know have
Brad Williams come over yeah right I
just need you to put this onesie on real
quick and cry a lot
did you move from that apartment to the
one you're in now party no I move from
that apartment into a 45 20 East West
43rd I'm Bob Kelly I lived in the same
building I had an amazing view I was in
the 22nd floor and um five months into a
two-year rent we got fired oh did you
did you think after moot did you think
you're gonna have to move back there oh
boy I was so depressed Oh to the first
time my career had the rug yanked out
front of me but then tough crowd came
along worked out but it's scary too and
you [ __ ] just sign something oh
that's what a month-to-month is good
yeah that's why I'm so scared to leave
it yeah yeah cuz I'm afraid I'm always
afraid that if I go to a nicer apartment
they're gonna be like we can't book you
anywhere and you have to go back to
waiting tables of Dos Caminos and then
I'm gonna be like plus there's something
nice about knowing that if you have to
move you can move today and we're gonna
do there's no lease there's no penalty
there's no security deposit there you
don't get yes yeah but only nice tape
you in Jersey or New York uh New York
upstate but you know like the transport
van meets on like Upper West so you
travel back and forth every day
yeah how far is the Droid it's like 3540
minutes
it's not upstate okay no not up say it's
like by the Palisades Mall
Wow so it's nyuk no yeah yeah
they keep you guys overnight no no
there's um no they've never kept us
overnight there's been an overnight
shoot but we've never like stayed
overnight anywhere I think they had to
for one scene when we're out in the
Hamptons does Damien and paul giamatti
ride in the valley you guys know they
are like different transportation for
them I had the top five people on the
call sheet have their own transportation
than the rest of us all get in the vans
it makes you realize where you are in
the business know when you're doing a
scene and you see the black SUV parked
right outside the trailers and you're
like okay I'm does not have to wait for
a van to go back to the city yeah there
was there was a moment yesterday when we
were filming and I to come back to do
the bonfire and I was like hey I need to
leave like pretty soon because I have a
radio show and they're like we'll see
when the next van is okay sometimes you
have to uber out of there so they're
over high doober I do BER one time I
think for a set like I was at the cellar
and I was like I have to do uber from
Nyack to the cellar yeah that sucks I'm
well you know I tried to avange 40
minutes 40 minutes and you're like and
then I'd have to stop on the Upper West
and get on the train and go down and I
was like man I just need to [ __ ] get
like it was cutting it close where I
think I got right to like texting Val
like I'm there like walking in and going
up yeah and that's [ __ ] terrifying
stressful yeah because it's like I don't
want to I don't want to [ __ ] piss
everyone off at the cellar like why the
[ __ ] is he late and that kind of [ __ ]
and then it's like the stress of they're
like well we just we might see you in
this next shot and you're like I have to
go yeah does that [ __ ] with you at all
like because when you first get the role
it's like holy [ __ ] I'm on this show
that's amazing like this is a go bah bah
bah and then you're like but I'm I'm in
the van though I'm not in one of the SUV
okay [ __ ] god I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
take public transportation up there if
they want me yeah
yes it's please don't make me oh yeah
but it's still just like holy [ __ ]
there's no I mean like I think the best
part of that is being a comic you just
get treated like garbage on the road
yeah yeah you know until you start
selling tickets and I think it's like I
was just so used to being on the road
like that's the condo be up at 7 a.m.
for radio sit in that office you get a
cup of coffee so when I show up there
and like there's a snit there's craft
services and which like a coffee is
there anything you want you're like oh
why are you so nice and you like I'll
get it like no no we have someone who'll
get it no I'll do it
I'm very uncomfortable yeah me too no
I'll get you a coffee like even Roland
hears I get a coffee now I'm comfortable
enough with you guys yeah well I'll take
a coffee with milk of sugar but there
I'm like I'll do it myself
also that's the way I was raised by my
mom my mom was like you ain't [ __ ] like
growing up my mom's like you're not [ __ ]
do stuff you're for yourself so that
alone makes me uncomfortable
yeah I'm just so convinced that they're
gonna be like yeah just [ __ ] go and
get his car exactly you're like but you
over yeah I thought that was the day
that's what they do though they don't it
is part of the gig but you still feel
[ __ ] weird Isaac stand up whatever
you feel like ah you're so used to doing
[ __ ] by yourself just bizarre yeah it's
still there it's still nuts to me like
telling you know even just be talking to
damien and maggie siff today Ramdev off
you're right back
um yeah I've been offered a ride back
one time Damien um by David Costabile
who's like uh he plays wags he's awesome
but he's he gets a private man like
here's the Brooklyn a private van or a
private they gave like vans they don't
do like SUVs they do like just the
transport vans take them Damien gets a
van well they all do they all get like
but it's his own van yeah it's his own
yeah and then they take surprisingly an
SUV they take him like door-to-door as
whereas opposed like we have a pickup
point Wow and I get Cosmo gets a ride to
Brooklyn and he's great he's the [ __ ]
man yeah he's very good yeah he's like
an awesome guy to work with
I learned a lot of [ __ ] just by working
with that I would demand it sua your
diminutive and I mean even doing your
dough demanded how they'd be so great is
so great I'm just such a fringe
character I want an SUV may need an SUV
and no eye contact I will not speak to
the driver I will get in and I'll be
practicing my lines very loudly my bonus
and I for what they get in a van to
practice their lines and I'm so
embarrassing I'll tell you this though
there is sometimes [ __ ] we're like
you'll be and as a comic when you're
around actors not there's just like
occasionally I've heard no one that's
like a regular on the show but like
going to table reads sometimes like the
actors that they'll have do for like
readings at the table reads say some
actor [ __ ] and just as a comic I'm like
oh my stacked to [ __ ] one time this guy
was just this is recently happened this
guy was like writing something and I'm
you
to seeing guys right in the you know
joke notebooks or whatever and I'm just
sitting there I couldn't stop the
reaction and this girl goes what are you
riding and he goes a poem is audible
oh yeah like what I was like oh god and
it's like I can't be the dick yeah one
more comic there I could have just
started [ __ ] [ __ ] on it but I
could I was like ah because I felt
embarrassed that I made such an odd up
Homer oh are you home [ __ ] I wanted to
shake it rip it uh-oh roses are red
violets are blue you're fired country
punch in the throat we get out of this
van I know doesn't rhyme he was writing
a poem dog writes a poem I'm [ __ ]
creep Oh sometimes when I want to pass
the time on set I I bring my poetry
bunny and he's like a guy where he's
like you know he's a nice guy he's a
creep palms are for creeps
they really are yeah it was the jury
said it was just I was just too much of
a natural red palm tree no I don't the
family could say it without being
embarrassed like these like I'm writing
a poem like what the [ __ ] you need to be
beaten up for saying that yeah they hate
people who write poetry you do yes I
want to take you to like a slam poetry
night just to have you watch it just
watch Jim hey good what I lamp I don't
know I hate that [ __ ] they'll breathe
weird I kind of feel walking down the
stairs rise but they also fall I have
seen them in the glass book I kind of
want now that we talked about is lamb
pork
I want a slam poem to end every show and
it's just kind of a recap of what
happened on the show except it's a slam
poem talk radio walking away from the
mic there is black mold in your heart
yeah laughter ensued we went to break
Sebastian Bach came in Chang piece of
garbage
memorizing lines take two two two men
you to acting acting in life acting in
real life acting in an apartment without
windows yes
I don't know all right you're home I'm
just gonna say that at the cellar what I
see slam poetry I want to see some slam
poetry oh not really slam poetry is
really awful you know like it's really
lousy that's really lousy art form
whatsoever to write a slam poem without
this show yeah me too like in earnest
this get almost 800,000 views
I mean Adrian maybe starting tomorrow
you may be in charge of the slam poems
back friend she'll see I didn't believe
that I was beautiful so when people told
me I was beautiful I wanted to look them
in the eyes and ask them what that meant
what is beautiful what do you talk but
instead I would smile and say thank you
pretty people have it so tough I know
I'm arches I know you don't believe oh
oh you don't believe I know Hey look
she's getting deep here I wasn't to the
point that I believed that I wasn't
because of the way that I look
not because I'll put the piano in my
appearance I was not beautiful I'm
hearing I looked in the mirror and
thought that was just a poem he this is
the power you can see in a mirror is my
[ __ ] are you gonna feel it it doesn't
rhyme ya see my poems anymore you don't
have their bones it's just terrible it
really is just his uh this morning I
took a dump
I grabbed my squatty potty yes I knew it
would be painful I knew it would hurt
but I had to poop I had to poop poop had
to come out of my butt it had to go into
the toilet I had my squatty potty my
feet were on the squatty potty my knees
at my nipples like a baby I pooped in
the toilet this poem is called
evacuation I was having trouble going so
I leaned forward my breasts against my
knees I grabbed my ankles I shot blood
on the back don't come in Mike I'm in
the bathroom
Mike the door does not lock I am
evacuated get oh wow this must be good
oh yeah dangerous wormhole 25,000 like
500 older sister would play teacher
interns were me my stuff
rabbit in an American Girl doll she'd -
up at the end of the bed and teach us
whatever she'd learned in
now she teaches ESL at an elementary
school in Boston and everyone tells it's
the really better students it's the oh
god it's the way students it's his body
language the way he talks and he comes
to Mike's I was a kid and it's someone
that's like every word means something
he stopped and the words already going
out his mouth they're going through his
entire body is he a big slam poet he's
the biggest is he he's one of the
biggest in the world right now how do
you know this an American this I just
made it okay
I don't know Hana does not know how to
read in Spanish much less English but
she's doing all right I'm gonna Swami
just talking I hate that in slam poetry
like you act like the way he would just
make eye contact with somebody in the
audience like he's acting like this is a
thought he just had when every single
word is memorized I said over and over
as a comic it's just kind of like just
talk right that what he's getting
pointed right just talking why are you
making it all theatrical making it
[ __ ] up breathing to memorize National
Poetry Slam time there's a lot of my
bits memorized
fine fine right just talk let's see make
it normal you should you should do a set
like this though smoking I quit smoking
three years ago easily the most over
rated decision I've ever done Jack the
second whip what's the joke I can't I
can't I don't even know anymore